hello and happy Friday to everyone happy
Friday everyone my name is Joey this is
John Luke and we today I can be kicking
off first episode of our new Friday
stream entitled game dump and there's a
there's a good history behind the stream
and if John like if you want to take
over from yes so we just finished
building our putting together our new
game library for the office still work
in progress but we got all the games out
of the boxes and put them on shelves and
it's a lot crap is the problem a lot is
a lot of stuff I've never heard of her
bad stuff we have like I feel like at
least 500 plus Game Boy Advance games
and just like nonsense so we want to
have a curated library so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna be playing games
from that library and determining if
they are good enough to stay in our
library and if not we're gonna dump them
so this week our theme oh good yeah so
this week our theme is playstation one
disney games we're gonna be playing a
bunch of them we got The Little Mermaid
- we got Tarzan which you can hear in
the background some hot MIDI Phil
Collins Aladdin shares your planet and
102 Dalmatians only the hottest disney
games we're playing on an actual
playstation 1 by the way which is pretty
cool we got that all set up so once you
get into the game here and start with
Tarzan look at that alright so um we're
gonna get right into it this is a player
only game it does have a log sport
though so I'm playing with the analog
controller and so what we'll be doing
here is kind of going through each game
we're not going to play a whole lot just
enough to try and give us a good sense
of whether or not we want to keep it
there or not
alright well first we're just gonna
watch the actual movie
we can't stream this this is already
twitch it's gonna take us down just
confirm we've you've seen most of these
movies right yeah I've seen I've seen
all of them even Little Mermaid - I've
seen once I actually have not seen
Little Mermaid I don't remember nation's
seam Treasure Planet Tarzan don't
remember anything about 102 Dalmatians
this one the Aladdin one's a little bit
more interest to lower the that's a
little out there a lot of nonsense
happening other monkey's going on for
ape sorry Aladdin it's called nasira's
revenge- anning him for motion videos
here get to the game here alright and
guys if you just read you know uh again
this is game DUP our Friday stream don't
forget we do stream every weekday at 11
a.m.
Mondays through Fridays so make sure
tune in for those whenever you can and
subscribe to our Channel oh boy oh my
okay so this is a looks like a 2d
platformer wrist if I'm up a little bit
Joey okay okay
well it's two and a half D yeah alright
see that was a big thing with the
PlayStation yeah early 3d games I can
see how well this represents Tarzan's
vine-swinging abilities here I don't
think that was actually a Rosie
O'Donnell I'm pretty sure they use like
all these all the
fake voice actors just like Crash
Bandicoot this is exact same game
I collect the fruit all the one for
coins just out out in the jungle alright
coins are long lines you have to jump by
the way for those of you in check I will
be reading any questions comments things
you have to movie games they're stopping
me every couple seconds here this real
level okay Texas says I didn't know
Little Mermaid has a sequel it did
included the court starred her or
Ariel's daughter who it's like the
reverse of the first yeah it's a
reversal mermaid we're like she loves
the sea or she's she has human legs and
loves the sea and wants to spend time
and yeah there's a TI gotta clicked all
the letters it was like Donkey Kong yeah
yeah well my god it really is Donkey
Kong isn't it Wow most yeah you know
that's not a bad this not of bad games a
ripoff thinking about it I think you
should stop collecting the turk heads
because every time she or he comes in
and he's like hey you should collect
this
you can hear the even the music and
grabbing like more sparse than the via
the MIDI version the credits or the
opening screen actually was not paying
attention I don't think any of it
matters
there's good jump I don't think I can
attack oh I can throw poop no where's
that fruit fruit I mean if you have
unlimited fruit honestly it doesn't know
it doesn't look bad what did we review
it we want to try and like find out what
we what we gave this game okay Tarzan
review written on July 14 1999 oh that
tagline is pretty promise ok the lead is
even if a movie licensed game turns you
off this game is an exception and worth
taking a look at that's actually pretty
promising so I got a nice oh I can do it
oh there we go shake people yeah I say
you should you should kind of speed
through this I want to see Tarzan like
growing up I want to see some vines
swing in here no I'll collect those
Diane I'm sorry I'm not even thinking
cool man 1 3 5 5 1 3 3 5 5 says this was
reviewed on his 15th birthday
nice what if this was like the like the
the vine the surfing thing the tree
branches are pretty sure it does I
thought I saw them on the back of the
box to be like a sonic level yeah there
is it says right I want to get to that
surf on trees
no Archie is the speeder this night just
wait there
oh you exploded like a gazelle you just
mildly irritated the jungle for oh
that's not zooms all the way in
oh no I definitely missed some letters
as well as fine keep going get that page
get that page
I feel inclined to just ignore all the
collectibles in this game that's like
the whole point though true but we're
not we're not playing for that we're
playing play to determine whether or not
we want to keep this game and so far I
don't feel you know feel sorry about it
I just want to get to the the the tree
surfing
well I can't save by the way I we don't
have a memory card in this going 8 ok
we're gonna be going 8 bann I mean that
stuff we're gonna get more video we've
all seen Tarzan I hope it seems like it
changes the resolution when it does that
yeah it takes like resets
I hope it's obut but we will be able to
play this play this level too son of man
right think so Oh got the knife already
exactly what I wanted here in the Disney
kids Disney game I got the knife fine
thing James Drinkwater says randomly
knife animals to death just like that
was original he just said hey Tarzan see
these vine things and then he just ran
away right there but like if he didn't
finish the sentence yeah whoa okay well
nevermind okay wait so can I climb up it
yeah you see in the night and then I we
can swing no okay I don't y'all have
momentum
I wasn't sure to build up momentum for
keep moving keep moving
see in the movie he's quick he's agile
I'm curious if anyone in the chat has
any familiarity with this game did you
play this as a kid what are your
feelings on it did you like it then I
really want to try and get as many I
want to get other perspectives on these
games as well see excerpts from the
review essay the visuals aren't bad
that's pretty decent yeah seems like a
decent it controls pretty well because
it is just 2d hi hi haha says the
classic game I very love bare not or not
don't bother too much game dump it this
is just Donkey Kong Country wow I mean
we gained spot did give it a 7 point 8
back in 99 it's not bad that reviewer at
least from that that tagline sounded
pretty positive that's all just shank
him it's just left is like now we don't
want that see that see that 3d space
there yeah it does that sometimes we're
at all I hate that okay like every top
coin you have to jump up it's like
annoying cuz you're a monkey man but it
keeps it breaks the flow the game you
can't jump on things can you oh you're
gonna die oh just keep going
yeah fine swing Oh No ah into the abyss
I panicked thank you John look we only
have eight minutes left for this set for
this game we're still not adult tarzan
yet alright I'll try and hurry drew
what's the chat feel about this game so
far based off what they've seen how do
they feel about it people loved it
actually I got Dennis Koch said he owned
it as a kid and it was awesome
Emile says completing it over and over
as a kid
all right dang I mean it doesn't it
looks like a pretty decent price yeah
honestly this game is not bad like I'm
having a decent time with this okay can
you jump into the foreground at some
point I suppose trying to figure out can
you go forward or like down right there
ooh oops is levels like cheat Guba all
right let's do it
I forgot about that okay so cheat our
way through this game it's l1 r1 l1 r1
l1 r1 okay what all right l1 r1 for x
and then l2 and then our two oh you're
the best
sweet full gallons all right
hey I'm sure I lost it go to options
that go back just in case okay and then
go back okay
one L 2 R 2
did that work you lied to us they do it
faster
I heard a noise I heard something so if
I hit start now try it it didn't pull up
like a menu though now see this is just
putting me back in the beginning herbal
mmm
welcome to the jungle I mean oh god damn
yeah because we don't have the memory
card yeah we'll try we'll try one more
time but if not then we're not I'm not
playing this opening again by the way
that is on my list to get a memory card
because we don't have any memory cards
for all these systems oh it's just pick
a load next okay
and then pick load
okay so it's yes four times
[Music]
our one party
I didn't hear anything go back try an l1
r1 l1 r1 l1 r1 we might need a memory
hard to do this this might might it's
not looking very good for Tarzan Oh
oh boy
[Music]
oops is oh wait yeah we might need the
at least try the cheat menu you need
open cheat menu first okay okay a new
menu press left left right right up down
left right up up down down I'll go I'll
go back run it okay left left right
right up down left right up down
[Music]
does it not look now no it's not like
yeah I think we might any memory card to
do this alright I think we're gonna have
to make a pass on Tarzan here so what's
what's the call Joey what do you think
I'm a 7.8 GameSpy honestly I was i I was
kind of expecting I hate it right away
I don't know I think I think the the
main thing is that we did not get to the
tree surfing sections with adult Tarzan
yeah but that could be like the best
part who knows
and not to mention Tarzan is like
probably the best movie out of these
five yeah what is the chat thing like
I'm inclined to keep young kind of and
keep it to I'm kind of feeling just for
like I mean if you're gonna if you're
gonna keep like a good Disney movie game
it should be Tarzan should be a good
movie I'd be really upset if Treasure
Planet was the best game out of this
bunch cuz I hate that movie oh you hate
your pool okay I don't hate it I just
don't all laugh you don't get into that
all right so I think I think we're gonna
keep beer so let's open up keep in it
we're keeping it I was not expecting
dumping to not keep any of these but
Tarzan it's being kept I feel like we're
setting a bad precedent Joey you can't
be waters about this alright sorry to
all the Treasure Planet fans out there
we'll get to in a second but for now
that's gonna hate we are gonna go with
the Little Mermaid to put it upside down
and unlocks the secret ending oh boy do
I need a reason
oh just turn oh you turn the bathroom
I'm gonna open up the rest of these
these are actually sealed copies yeah
they're unopened which is great
there's a lot of games in there that
just aren't opened yeah we got a lot of
stuff by the way guys we're gonna try
and like keep going through different
systems each time back and forth we got
late and 64 stuff we it's a gameboy
advance Dreamcast we have engage which I
don't know how we're gonna play those
but we figure that one out
we have so many engaged games but no
system as far as I know so let's just
break it
Oh like the demo just that like I was
like wasn't that our original plan -
just like destroy the game yeah we try
them or not I don't know if I want to
destroy them I think what we'll do is
maybe like just keep them somewhere for
a while and then maybe like light it on
fire on stream ya later
enough Sebastian he's a little looting
crab no memory card found whoops too bad
so this one is uh Little Mermaid - let's
see one player is still analog
compatible we've got a vibration did
Tarzan in vibration sorry I'm trying I
did a vibration functionality actually
Treasure Planet oh man there's a lot we
can rescue Prince Erik search for clues
about my true identity conduct
Sebastian's Orchestra over 30 minutes of
movie footage so we can basically watch
like half of I think Tarzan had that -
right only knows probably treasure okay
so it just gives me like a level select
right here I guess we'll just start with
this one skulls nests
da says Hercules was actually pretty
good
I don't know if we have that one we
don't have but I will I can imagine what
that time all the Disney movies Hercules
is maybe in my top story that's over I
can only show so much time don't worry
about pants we're not planning on
destroying any games any games yet all
right so I'm assuming we are just
playing through the regular the story
mode right now
yes holy crap I'm less impressed with
this one so far can shock shock do you
have like what electricity murder
korban sounds like her might be the
voice actors no that's not her good look
like our good sound like those icons are
very like early table oh my God look at
her face
good lord the untold stories of all of
Ariel's sisters okay we're getting meta
with this one is this a 3d space or is
it still now and I shall do that flip
when she moves which is Glee's asking
did we play spyro or do we pay spiral
but I'm assuming needs to play
no we haven't played ran out of flying
Disney games we do have a Spyro 1 and 3
is she just in the way
I'm trying freakin can't wait for her to
go okay can't wait to go back down can
you scoot down a little bit
oh no no no she's like oh she's
following you she's following me
whatever screw it
oh we can go the other way okay okay
I'm not into these it's very sluggish
[Music]
ragging on the band right in front of
them these guys suck
we gotta play them later battle pants is
Sebastian Jamaican well his accent is
supposed to be so I'm not sure we're
actually I think the The Little Mermaid
takes place in the Atlantic sea so this
is like before the Little Mermaid this
is also a Little Mermaid one yeah why is
it oh man no we're gonna have to play
through both of them oh yeah it's
basically both movies so it's like Oh
sounds like a two-for-one package
where's my shock I think it's a triangle
no I just do this kind of spin thing hey
I picked up a comb oh you found her comb
it's basically with that jellyfish James
Drinkwater says l1 l1 r1 r1 X 22 6 27
times while holding down the d-pad on
the title screen unlocks topless aerial
mode keep the seashells in place oh my
god
we do that goodness so like spin attack
yeah real did have that in the game or
in the movie I was because a bow has
from Sweden the Swedish version of
Sebastian sounds more like a pirate ooh
that's interesting
primo primo ball says play now and I
don't know that we have that one either
sure um we had a Game Boy Advance
version of um like Peter Pan the motion
picture experience or whatever it was it
was like the 2001 live-action Peter Pan
yeah very well that translates into it
wow you have a key now okay I got a cup
for the chest okay well let's do this
spin hey and welcome my speedrun of a
Little Mermaid - I guarantee you there's
someone out there that can beat this in
like 40 minutes maybe maybe even be even
shorter than that can we got a bag now
so we can go treasure-hunting
this is your mode of transportation down
to spiral what do yes you do
I have to go find the ring another pearl
okay time for your [ __ ] I say I'm not
impressed for this one what did we give
it what look up the okay Liz James says
Ariel has invited psycho crusher Ariel
and I Street Fighter 5 confirmed ID
watch-like' a look at a classic animated
Disney character it's like a fighting
game that'd be pretty good you know the
street fighter versus everything you
know there's Capcom vs. Marvel Marvel is
owned by Disney it's basically like just
the doorway dropping them from putting
Ariel in the game or Tarzan at least
he's got that shank yeah exactly
GameSpot actually didn't review the
Little Mermaid by Gian
IGN let me see they gave it a 7
ok
standards were different back then I
guess they were well I mean 2001 or
actually - December 25th this this came
out on Christmas Day 2000 it it was in
the tuba sweet saxophone
ya da Ariel and sfii confirmed ok some
hot MIDI ok I think it's no I say listen
oh alright
ring let's give it to the dad I love how
the main order is game play any better
downwards weather wetter under the sea
you got a read on to find out oh that's
a hot I'm just gonna go straight to the
to the end presentation Guthrie it's a
Disney movie with the dizzy story so why
not let that story flow and sparkle
doesn't sound like a three I think
they're saying like it doesn't let it
float him sparkle like they're just sort
of sad about okay get some coins we're
going in this okay let me let me read
you the verdict because I there's
something about this okay it's not quite
anything special but if you're looking
for a game that your daughter or if you
are a daughter and are looking for a
game for yourself be you 18 or 81 or
even if you're interested in someone
else's daughter what you see a teen or
81 there's no shame and enjoying this
game that's a real thing someone wrote
what if you're interested in so else a
daughter this is a game you can you guys
if you like macking on 18 year old do I
got the video game for you
all going to the shipwreck graveyard
perfect timing where we'll find the
bones of whoever wrote that they just
they just tied into a by the way if you
guys are just joining us oh we are
playing a bunch of ps1 old ps1 disney
games terminating if they're good or not
for our library I love up giving anyone
else notice Larry all the related faces
look close up yeah they don't they don't
look great
not even just like the 3d models but the
the little 2d portraits that they have
over the text those are looking too not
great so is that your shock or is that
your fats hi a fast attack so what that
is a shock strangled sir I can't do
anything with that it just does that
that's shocking oh wait there we go
because I can't do when I'm moving she
has like psychic powers
she is bison Wow
no star wait for your health for health
that's what my mom always said to me
[Music]
you're just gonna let that shark swim
around now I can use my psycho crusher
on it then the background or is it not
the bat yes the background huh see there
is avoid him
it ate something munched on something
that the snarl oh that shell is your
health actually yeah blue I want to help
then you go down we have a key got the
spoon yeah her zoning game is too strong
control see a bit sluggish yeah they're
a little bit sluggish sigh Berkman's
anyone is asking anyone remember playing
Mickey Mania on ps1 actually I don't
remember that one
and he's also a C and a ps1 game made up
of many Disney movies like a mash-up of
some sort ah
just floating all right that sharks yeah
one drill yeah swim use your psycho
crusher headfirst into the ground
no no keep going oh my god oh okay no
it's fine we're not in the same place oh
never mind
I'll just spit you out and then she
laughs
James drink water you're right this is a
terrible what are we at we are we got
nine minutes left on this maybe maybe go
to one of the other sheriff areas
because we're playing Little Mermaid -
but we haven't seen her daughter at all
well I don't think we have a choice
alright now I know scuttles miss the
tribe boys we don't turn it off we're
fine treasure trove okay treasure trove
is that's right we got the manual
treasure trove is when you find like a
new special item so it's not that I just
have to keep playing the game then you
have to start what snarf blast well
that's the the pipe that you found
that's what he calls it
what's that do I all know all that's
options oh cool
I'm glad you made that very clear for me
oh it's just the bottom options I see
view film clips let's just play the game
this is so slow let me know let's select
a yeah if I just want to land to Cove
restart the game okay well we're gonna
try that other one one more time yeah do
Nicktoons games we have a lot of
Nickelodeon game for like game boy I
know okay yeah boy yes I Berkman she
actually got eaten which i guess is not
surprising since it is a short but it's
spanner out it's not like yeah that was
weird
it's not like us going for anything like
no gory this case games I was used to
break into two for me yeah a lot of ours
are like not in good shape
well some of these were actually sealed
copies so they're okay for now so we
have a couple like for example are our
Spiro case is kind of busted so if we
like get rid of say like Treasure Planet
we know it's a good case so we should
swap it with so that we have like
actually some nice cases for the good
ones I don't think we're gonna get to
the low mermaid to at this point
as much as like as much as I appreciate
how chock-full of content this game is I
don't think it's good now I know I'm on
the I'm on the boat which is uh
currently sinking on this game
you stop for everything don't get that
health your health your help
psycho crusher is never gonna get old
okay at least we know our way around
here kind of Dan Cory oh yeah we know
this game is bad I think we've already
we've already judged it we've already
made our decision
we're just trying to try to go through
the allotted time that we have we have
five minutes left for the Little Mermaid
to segment at the very least we want to
see what's beyond this level
we'll see if I can get away from the
shirt so those are obstacles I was like
so close then get that pearl what do you
eat you if you just went into his mouth
psycho power hey that was the whole
level all right four minutes left to
impress us
all right burning burning [ __ ] we
might be able to see Prince Eric can
save him right that's what it say on the
button in the back yeah
rescue yeah oh my god you guys can't see
it but like respirator Eric here looks
pretty hilarious he's just like a white
and blue blob skoobs skoobs combat
levels like remove disc snap in half
throwing trash press r2 what's the next
game we think we're gonna pick after
this let's go with let's go with
Treasure Planet okay I opened that one
up so we'll do that one next
oh my you know some about the the
resolution on this PlayStation 1 game
doesn't really do the animation just
really doesn't they just want this to
shove them in there at some point
ooh nice lighting effects but that fire
going on upstairs oh no he's got his own
health bar
alright you got three bits to save
Prince Eric oh but all the remotes are
hurting yeah
is this it his little roommate set in a
time when like speedboats weren't
invented yet
like I assume this takes place in like
the 1800s yeah yeah where's like they're
all just like she wouldn't she win get
caught in like a boats propeller like
torn up oh you guys face hurry we have
to pick this stuff up
I know praise Erica's drowning but like
this pearl looks really nice oh my see
barrels of gunpowder you guy go through
the boat or under the boat okay all
right where is he who's steering wheel
there's a little kind of weird like the
world a lot of times the stuff that's
hitting you is not in the same like
foreground yeah aerial so I can't tell
like Oh am i safe with this or not most
of most of Eric's uh oh there he is most
of Eric's crew members just abandon ship
right away and got into the rowboat
while he's like in the water dying what
do i press I guess I got it we're
cruising through this one I know
dang alright well we're already going
yeah do we got - MS I get to Ursula now
do we can maybe get to it in two minutes
let's find out
journey to Ursula HD our implementation
is great oh yeah it's a fix
4k you know I wasn't really convinced on
the Xbox one X when I saw it at e3 but
after seeing this game I might have to
buy one we got the Eels you can't skip
any of this
whoa boy that's a good song I do like
the I do quite like her slow song Ursula
like I was I just love her voice actor
like it's so right boy stur she's I
forget her name but like she's she's
done a lot of work I think she might
have like passed away recently ooh
buzz let your star command I flayed that
one myself I don't know if we have a
copy of it here but we do have Toy Story
2 which is another one yeah we have Toy
Story 2 and three throws for like that
be like Xbox 360s pearl all right we're
running we're running out of time come
if you want to get to her and then we'll
then we'll call it or if you die
oh here we are
okay so this is this will be the last
level that will play I'm glad too
because this is really changing my whole
opinion oh I know oh yeah pet Carol that
was a name oh and she's still alive oh
sorry about that might been thinking
about someone else that another voice
actor Oh short I know I was thinking I
was thinking of the the lady who played
like rocky from Rocky and Bullwinkle Oh
like she passed away like last week was
it like that she's done like she's like
90 something years old we've done like
one since the forties and fifties you
just ignoring all these like all these
Jets of like steaming scalding liquid
it's hard to tell if it's actually like
it can't affect me some of it does the
happy guy what is this this is our new
Friday show called game dump in which we
go through a bunch of old crappy games
from our game library next door and we
decide whether or not we want to keep
them we've gone through Tarzan for ps1
so far we're gonna keep that and
currently we're doing The Little Mermaid
- it doesn't look like it considering
it's just a little levels from The
Little Mermaid one right now
false advertising no I wanted Little
Mermaid - I wanted melody I wanted to
play melody my favorite mermaid
character my favorite mermaid
can't be level alright if I if I don't
get an Ursula song here I am inclined to
dump this let's find out we have to play
Ursula's lair I was just like getting
there we're just watching the movie not
awesome this is after poor unfortunate
souls
well it's good skip that is are we gonna
be humans really speeding through this
plot ha game well they have to get to
the sequel oh that's where they really
take ok let's take this this moment to
decide now gentlemen we're gonna dump it
we're dumping this one this one's mmm
fortunately we're sorry the target 1
seems like a pretty decent Donkey Kong
Country clone this is just this is like
like Freddy the fish level hey Freddy
fish at least no I mean in terms of like
the way it looks
Freddy fishes is a adventure game oh
this is a boss right here what all right
we got at least fighter I mean you're
not gonna kill her that's that's for
later right
psycho crush come on
oh we have to shoot all you have to hit
those bottles that are like go do spin
attack etre
is only the red ones that work I don't
know it might be yeah it's the red ones
get her no it doesn't let me go closer
oh you have to oh my god it's gonna take
you that blue shell on the right is for
life bar is really yeah you're gonna
have to throw a lot of red files at her
so I remain since can you play Lion King
or Aladdin we have an Aladdin game we'll
get to that one get to that one after
that after Treasure Planet which we are
going to do right now I'm sorry jean-luc
I'm cutting you off I'm okay get get rid
of it oh all right so it's a resilient
resounding no for the little guy a dump
alright so we are going to be moving on
Treasure Planet yeah wait what happened
to the oh I dropped it oh it's gone now
here it is okay so let's let's just lay
this down where did your grievances with
Treasure Planet the movie I think I was
just mad at the fact that like it's
literally just Treasure Island yeah it's
just Treasure Island it like it this was
during an era where like Disney movies
were this was like past the the the
Renaissance of the 90s and like right
they were experimenting more more with
3d it looked pretty good but like this I
don't know for some reason I felt like
the story was just like oh I'll admit
that it doesn't really feel like it adds
much new to the Treasure Island
narrative yeah like I thought if I was
to watch a treasure island movie I'd
actually probably watch them up it's
Treasure Island yeah cuz that one's got
Jim Carrey in it is Jim Carrey yeah Jim
Carrey Jim Carrey Tim Curry I'm sorry
Tim Curry and then Jim Carrey always
forget that guy's name the bad guy with
the beard but I confuse Jim Carrey in
tenth grade because it's like two R's
Tim Jim
ships with cargoes Oh Oh Nick wants to
know are we throwing these games away
are we keeping them well hold on to him
for now yeah we're hold on now we're not
keeping them in there I'm gonna keep me
I'll keep him in my my desk for the
moment this is Tony Jay was the
notorious captain which is kind of weird
because he did you watch Hunchback of
Notre Dame
oh yeah that three doesn't hold up well
that's good point I didn't oh he's like
narrating Treasure Planet
all right have the chat skin on me for
saying a Jim Carrey Jim Jim curry Carrie
those are very similar without a trace
oh wait let's move on someone also says
who cares about Disney play parappa I
love referring to your shirt which is
awesome if we ever find a chance to play
if we find like a parappa no we won't
play on game dumb but I'll find I'll
find chance let's just start it up play
prep at some point well the menu was
fast on that one so this one already
gets points responses yeah just quick
quick into it we're gonna skip these all
right in the meantime I'm gonna be
opening up Aladdin
this is revenge they kept saying my desk
is a trash can now yeah kind of
I'll be the new Mary Mary Kish desk from
that like really annoying robot
well this one's full 3d whoa I'm not
sure oh good thing I have the analog
stick let me play things but it's
inverted left to right now oh okay bad
version it's the one that no one likes
your sword for instance why can't I skip
this
oh you can try changing the options oh I
have to hit down that's weird
what camera passive active well an
active see what happens well turn the
vibration on yeah I'll set up sound now
I can't move it
oh it's like it doesn't on it doesn't
poor you souls like Zelda or something
yeah mark Simon Says funny how these
games were cool as a kid and now it's
like right yeah I feel like that's that
can be the case for a lot of like these
I know the the early 3d games like in
the ps2 or ps4 and 64 era now I can
double jump like there are a lot of
things about like infinity games I just
don't really hold up such as this like
there's still experimenting with a lot
of like just yeah Kanaks and everyone
was trying to emulate like mario 64 in
some capacity now i don't think i'm so
safe alright let's look at the review
for this one though i'm curious because
all the inverted camera this was a
little bit later than resin and
Wilmerding
- oh wow
they what weapon lasering I guess laser
well I have a laser he said I have a
laser shoot something I can't oh well
just a ray gun ah this door appears to
be locked Jim looks like you'll need to
zap a switch somewhere in the immediate
vicinity that may open it right up
someone's asking about movie basically
if they're all movie based games yeah
all Disney games does he didn't there
was a period where Disney was like
making their own games very very briefly
in the mid two thousands but nothing
will ever be as good as the 16-bit era
ones though I think can you know I just
shot a shoot all right
looking up the Treasure Planet review on
GameSpot calm the lead says Treasure
Planet isn't a bad game it just might be
a little too easy for experienced
players I'm not I'm not feeling that
yeah there's not much to it right now
it's kind of sparse right now yeah oh
boy oh let's get this kid what is that I
will run around scaring the birds into
the air so you can shoot them as far as
aggressive to my eyeballs
yeah just d-pad in circle for circle
okay it's just like hunting now
[Music]
okay this is calm
did you see that chip of those people
who recreated duck hunt and halo no
that's pretty good they like they had
one guy like really far away and they
created the like the level design of
duck hunt and so they have I guess I
have like low gravity on and people were
just jumping around like that's really
good like all the way the distancing you
just trying to snipe try and psyphon
that's awesome way better than what this
appears to be hunter line says the only
good Disney game was the first Epic
Mickey
we have a copy of a copy - oh yeah that
big - we also have a power of illusion
the remake was for the Wii right knows
for the Game Boy I feel like the D s or
like 3d s yeah I heard it wasn't very
good though
like it was essentially like a remake of
the the old Epic Mickey Castle of
illusion game I think it was called
Castle of illusion
yeah oh oh yeah that one I remember that
many people really excited they're like
whoa they're doing like a throwback like
remake and it like wasn't very good
apparently level of games as very few
movie video games have been successful
and the other way around video game
movies yeah what is your like mutual
like terribleness between the house I
really things what would you say is like
your your favorite like movie licensed
game or like some that you move you'll
respond the Behaim oh man I mean you
know everyone likes the uh like you know
SNES Lion King Aladdin
right I think the Genesis I mean I'm in
the camp of the genesis aladdin I feel
like that one is the superior one
and I knew mafioso spider-man - that's
yep we have a copy of smart man - we
have so many PlayStation 2 games oh ok
so how long is this going on for this is
really long we're running low on time
here and I feel like we haven't done
very much
yeah nadir I hope the the new spider-man
game is good oh yeah me too I wasn't
terribly impressed with what they showed
though there's a lot of lot of QuickTime
events
yeah that's kind of its kind of flashy
but and we'll see how it I wanted to see
more dislikes oh look Jim no I'm not
trying that again ok this is a blade
runner for the PUC yeah that's actually
pretty cool that's an adventure game
that actually has multiple and he never
plays oh that one's actually pretty rare
oh is it like the ohm that those any of
the Joe's games kind of its 3d and there
would be actual like differences like
you're you were a separate character but
it was a Blade Runner but you know there
was actually the potential to like be a
replicant or not like there would be
like randomized certain elements like
certain characters would be so you
wouldn't know until the end maybe so
yeah yeah that was like part of the game
well it's time to figure that out so
that was actually kind of neat my
personal favorites probably Chronicles
of Riddick escape from butcher Bay oh
yeah then we have the copy of that
somewhere we have a couple copies of
that and I'm actually getting oh I want
to play that a little sick especially
because uh I actually think the ex Rijal
Xbox version actually still looks a
little better than the remaster because
of the way that the lighting they did
the lighting there's a certain way the
shadows in the Lighting's worked in the
original version that they could
replicate outside of the Xbox Hardware
that I think looks at least that's what
I remember I'd be curious like when we
do our Xbox games
maybe we'll put that on there maybe yeah
that's the thing is we're probably not
gonna play any obvious games like we're
not gonna be playing like Mario 64 yeah
or anything like that ones are like
borderline ever like we asked a we if we
look at a game and ask ourselves why do
we have this or or is this good then
maybe it'll appear on this now there are
some games that even if they're bad we
might still keep it they like are kind
of like infamous for their like you know
like they're well-known yeah I'm
thinking of games like I'm like the
novelty like red steel right like I
remember red still being a bad game and
we'll get the red steel on the Wii yeah
I'll probably still be a bad game but
things like such a well known bad game
it was you know a launch game for them
yeah so we there's something to be said
about kind of keeping that one around
like historical reasons right Bob Jones
superman 64 yeah if we we had it we if
we how do we keep it there's no reason
why you wouldn't yeah do a DS game dump
we have we have a very a lot of them a
lot of them outside of their cases by
the way I don't know this is before we
work here but a lot of people just took
like DS games out of their cases and
like threw away like PlayStation 2 boxes
and they're monsters they're monsters
I'm trying to figure out like what's the
best way to handle this it might not be
a perfect solution if in terms of
authenticity but you can buy like
replacement cases and then we could
always there is a really great website
called the cover project where they um
they have high-res scans of every single
game cover and we call we print out the
covers that's why we have the three or
four copies of Deal or No Deal so that
wouldn't be a perfect solution because
it's not like an authentic box but if we
just want to like have the boxes for
some of them that might be the best way
to do it
Liz James asks does conquer count had
scenes from multiple movies parody yeah
although I did I remember
I always used to play the The Matrix
jump to it uh hunter line says his
favorite movie based game was open
season we have open season
I remember that one being infamous for
like trophy collection or like play say
collectibles know like like achievements
like Xbox achievements oh wait what what
do you mean I guess like it was a really
easy one to get achievements for to get
like a thousand gamer point yeah yeah
like there is um do you remember that um
the Avatar game that they yes they can
have we have like that two minutes and
you get like a thousand I think we have
that as well so yeah then back when
people like I knew people who would on
like rent cheap games that they knew
were had easy achievements just you know
you could get them and I think open
season was one of those who says do you
have Disney Kitchen I don't think so
I've never heard of this let me says I
would like to see a double O seven game
dome we do have a bunch of double of
seven games so we can absolutely do a
James Bond boy I think we have these not
enough on the n64 we have I think we
have nightfire okay you might have the
the Goldeneye remake we do else is there
do they make games for like Casino
Royale or anything recent
uh I gotta I'm kinda with the DA who
says this doesn't seem bad but it's
boring yeah it's like well enough made
for a PlayStation 1 game but I'm pretty
bored David now says ok I have a problem
why isn't morph with Jim right now yeah
man scream ooh
Marcus brings up a chicken run we have a
copy chicken run for the Dreamcast and I
played that a lot as a kid actually
actually another game that I played a
lot as a kid you don't screw a little
bit we're something when I play as a kid
I mean I'm ready to I think I'm ready to
kind of get off this one okay yeah we're
almost out of time for Treasure Planet
I say let's just get rid of it now
honestly okay I'm done okay a blady
wrasses asks us are we playing on
emulator no we are actually playing on
an actual PlayStation 1 here's the disc
right here to prove it we are trying to
keep it as authentic as possible here on
game dump we're gonna judge these games
we're gonna judge it on the original
hardware with the original controllers
we even have the 9 like stick
controllers although all of these have
analog supports so I'm gonna play them
with analog because like I'm not a crazy
person
all right so let's next up we are gonna
go with 102 Dalmatians Oh puppies to the
rescue I think we're deciding charge
appliances no no we're gonna we're gonna
dump it sorry
reaping the dumped ones right now
actually well over here we need like a
we need like a garbage can with the logo
on it and then we can like trash it
every time when you pulled it up but
yeah the one game I played a lot as a
kid that I really really loved and
probably doesn't hold up but I would
like to try find out it's the Grinch oh
did you say you plate used to play that
late a lost kid and we have a copy of it
so that's that's gonna be an interesting
one a couple good ass
Justin so in saying Harry Potter games
we were talking about that we have a
Harry Potter you know we were thinking
of doing something like there's Crystal
Dynamics whoa what is yes it's I notice
you don't see high dose yeah we were we
were before they took over the Tomb
Raider franchise I know this is this is
a precursor whoa we were thinking about
doing like a Harry Potter theme one
where we just played through all seven I
think this is well seven or eight
depending on if they help with the split
allows me yeah the other the other issue
is that they did but the other issues
that we have like Game Boy Advance
versions and we have like console
versions so you might have to do a
multiple yeah that vasenka says he
played the [ __ ] out of 102 Dalmatians as
a kid what do you think it tell us if
you were to replay if you will actually
just looking at it right now
turn that vibration I saw fight to fall
like all the spots are just continuously
popping up in the menu I don't remember
anything about this movie 102 Dalmatians
well it wasn't it I I can't remember
feels the straight-to-video or not a
bug's life I actually we actually have a
copy of that we were I remember thinking
about putting it in here but we decided
to go with these instead actually
remember apply mask it Travis Woodward
says Emperor's New Groove I don't know
if we have a copy know about Barbie
games I'm sure we have a couple I don't
remember seeing any though wait what
just happened because it's tech goob
says why do you buy console instead of
themed so it's both we're typically
doing me buy one console and then within
there yeah it'd be a little bit more
difficult to like play all the Harry
Potter games if we had them for like ps2
ps1 game boy advance and swapping in and
out consoles on a streamers a little bit
of a hassle oh my god
teller helper says if you actually throw
away the games you don't want instead
giving them away or selling you GameSpot
dead well we haven't officially decided
to to like trash them or like like
destroy them in any form but we'll see
maybe maybe maybe something that's
something to consider for the future
we're not gonna ditch em right away
don't worry
Marcus army says it was straight to
video 102 yeah I know the whole story is
that Carell is still out apparently and
then they have one more domination
without any spots and that's her that's
not a Dalmatian at all this movies about
was it about racism something like that
oh good Frankie Muniz is the voice of
Domino I think dominoes boys let's hear
it we can hear them you know we can we
skip this at all maybe I was kind of let
it play out because it's an actual awake
cutscene yeah is this the first one that
doesn't just even have like clips from
the you know movie I don't think doesn't
look like it audio I mean yeah but like
it's okay for a PlayStation 1 game to be
honest well let's see well it's it's
hard for me to gauge what you is this
weight sector is Frankie Mir as what so
he is in the movie then right I don't
know I'd be really weird if he wasn't in
the movie and they got him for the game
he was he was big around this time right
around 2000 that's when um oh yeah he
was like it was like right was right
during the height of malcolm in the
middle' and then we had a big fat liar
what does the movie I loved as a kid did
you see the sequel to that big fat liar
oh I saw you tweet a big fat liar that
was released last year
that's insane it was it's so bad I think
that I was a like big fat lie was about
him writing like a movie right he
basically wrote stolen wrote a a a story
for class and then it this it ended up
getting falling into the hands of the
movie studio executive yeah who was like
this is actually really good this could
make a good movie and you basically
adopt it to a script and sold the kids
idea so so bigger fatter liar is there a
is the exact same story
I can't skip these oh no it's the exact
same story except it it's about this guy
who looks like some vine douchebag
who creates an app and he has that
stolen by this game creator that he like
I assume it's the same thing he gets to
do a car or a bike accident so he like
drives right first knock against this
game this is analog control compatible
analog stick you have to turn on maybe
but the other ones I didn't have to
maybe that maybe ah oh he's gonna hit
that but the other ones I didn't how
would I know
have we ever played Pepsi man now I
played cool spot but not Pepsi man
that's the this music is the extent of
my soda themed video game
I got a bone
soin says I have PS my home but don't
collect drop for that car let's not
think about game collecting is I'm not
as me personally I understand someone
who's like I want to collect every game
yeah I'm not I just want to collect like
the games that I need I care about yeah
that's that's kind of how I feel about
to and that's kind of how I feel like we
are treating our library is we're not
necessarily like we're gonna if we were
gonna keep everything we could keep it
all but yeah like no no we want to keep
games that people actually want to go
back and go I mean it's it's one thing
to be like a collector as in oh I want
to have like a comprehensive collection
like for example I've seen people who
who have collected like every single we
game ever made yeah like that's their
thing like that says there's some poppin
I could turn down the volume there you
go I'm sitting there talking about the
graphics right I think they meant audio
audio pop what me like pop in the bike
it change graphic settings Oh turn the
center I don't know I'm just gonna turn
the music down side workman's asking you
have either let's play JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure no actually haven't we got
some really cool ones on place that we
found um uh SNK vs. Capcom yeah the
original the original unopened and I
think it is also an opened it's a copy
of the original Marvel vs. Capcom
oh that's unopened I think it's not open
it might and it might be opened well
either way we have it either way we have
it and you were saying that actually
goes for a decent amount of money yeah
not that we're gonna sell no no no we're
not planning on selling it but that's
that's actually pretty cool like that's
the one you can tell like a lot of these
older games like people in the office
probably took the good ones for
themselves
so like going through the PlayStation 1
games it's like okay it's like we don't
have any of the original tomb raider
games you know we don't have like a lot
of the dreamcast games we have are just
a lot of like spores yeah we don't have
people where Sonic Adventure anything
for the dreamcast or samba de amigo or
fantasy star like clearly people took
all the good [ __ ] we have Floyd game
brothers
when open I'm now wondering if it is Oh
No I know the case is cracked a little
bit oh is it
yeah Marvel for Marvel but um there are
actually a couple examples where the
cases are cracked but the plastic still
on it yeah what am I doing here
I have no idea I think you're clicking
bones okay I've been collecting them no
it hurt me
I don't like try though to meet over me
I got it you got 11 can you leave this
is this game to slightly give me a
slight headache no it's fair oh the
second area there we go so what are in
those boxes in can you like attack oh
I'm supposed to be finding the other
Dalmatians I'll go back then there is
totally another one over there
level Games's play a Sonic game dump a
high already man
I played someone talk to this guy about
Sonic games here oh boy
exactly what you should be dumping even
the bad ones though like I mean if you
have a copy of sonic oh six is worth
keeping around yeah Fred old Fred laughs
like I feel like Sonic is is a series
that is worthy of like keeping all the
iterations just for a great series it's
so notable like even though it's like
man would I ever play Sonic Unleashed
again no but like should we keep it
probably
oops it's a dump all the song Keys easy
Genesis we don't actually only have one
we only have two Jessa's carts the
original something the hedgehog assign
the hedgehog and the I think the first
ever John Madden football yeah it's like
unopened - Walter D'Amico says the only
nice dog game I played was dog's life on
ps2 I'm familiar with that game was that
the one where you like take care o
of a dog like you know that's like your
that's like a 3d platforming game in ten
dogs is actually a good game we have a
couple yeah I was thinking of like the
horse games that came out like probably
around the same time where you like
raise horses was for that weird
subsection look at a giant 102 we just
love horses someone's asking we tasked
to clean up the library you're doing
this by choice now this is a hundred
percent choice like that library thing
that was a mean Nick margarita just
wanting to do that for a while yeah any
of you guys had seen any of you guys had
seen the library back when it was still
just a big fat mess yeah I wouldn't
really call a library then we basically
turned it into one yeah like we're
getting more shelves we're gonna
actually hook up all these old consoles
and we're gonna have them all set up for
playing capture we just wanted to create
like a really cool like room that's just
full of like games that people can just
check out on that play Texas's okami is
the best dog game Oh commies cool we got
we got a commie
no no oh you're in a pet store now rock
band game dump concert maybe uh oh if
we'd be able to do rock band in here now
we're trying to figure out how we're
gonna do we in here actually just keep
falling off oh my god it's like okay
it's like slippery oh you have to fire
cracker on a car in a pet store is this
okay oh just keep sliding oh my god
leggo Rahman that's the only rock band I
never owned I'm kind of disappointed
because I remember when it came out I
think we have that I was gonna go pick
it up at UM where was it I was gonna go
pick it up somewhere on I'm like Black
Friday one like back in two thousand
seven or eight or whatever and at the
Old Navy mixture at the Old Navy
downtown they had like a setup before
people would go in there and you could
just play and that was the only time I
ever played Lego rock band and I kind of
kind of wish I like found the copy for
myself because there's some good songs
in there this is bad stories on my junk
rats Oh Twilight Princess kind of a dog
game yeah all right let's put star
turned into a castle mansion good oh
this camp no it's sliding I'm gonna get
so many bones the hell is that we could
squirt
thrilling stuff
have you played medieval for the ps1
actually I've never played it and there
that that box sorry is kind of grained
into my like memory just from all the
ads that they had in like the old
magazines da yes there was a Lego rock
band I think I feel like it was a little
bit short-lived was kind of like a
spin-off thing that it didn't really
sell all that well so they making a
second a follow-up for that do you guys
have Spyro yeah we have Spyro 1 in queue
I think you're the Dragon 2 sorry sorry
no one in three we don't have to yeah we
have you're the dragon and we have B
result was the year of the dragon the
one with Elijah Wood no Elijah Wood was
later we have a we actually have other
Spyro like the later ones as well I so
we probably do have one of the ones I'm
not even playing him it's weirdest
lightly motions - yeah it seems like a
lot of people are we can move on from
this one honestly if you wanna we well
we got four minutes left
officially this is a but I I'll agree
that if if a game is worthy of like a
quick dump like if we don't want to
spend like the for twenty minutes on it
then we can like decide to dump it early
Oh will we play muscle March on the Wii
oh is that the one with like he's naked
buff men right for some reason muscle
March here let me let me look it up real
quick I vaguely remember that game yeah
do you remember this
no muscle March cool I don't really know
the here it is I don't really know the
premise of the game I just know that
there's just like these buff men and
speedos and then you there's probably
some minigames attached to it let's get
off this one this one's kind of whatever
okay yeah doggie dump
let's just get blowing up that's fine I
ate the cheeseburger all right are we
are we dumping dump it 102 dump Nations
sorry down the tube it goes all right
and so finally presenting these pups to
the shelter the kill shelter that kills
you could just say the UH we're gonna
put we're gonna put this game to sleep
well this one has an advertisement for
the Emperor's New Groove game Oh looks
pretty good okay so we got the last game
our stream today which is Aladdin
nasira's revenge- out was not in any of
the movies I don't believe he might be
in the TV show though says featuring
original character voices from the hit
TV series is that including Ron Williams
or did he not do the TV show he did not
do the TV show was it what dan
Castellaneta cuz he did return I
remember he did return too far when
there was like that the whole thing
about Bob Williams being upset about or
being upset with Disney for some reason
oh there was like there was like some
problem about there was like an
agreement with Ron Williams and Disney
that Disney would not use like his name
or use the genie as as like that big of
a marketing tool for Aladdin because Ron
Williams had his own movie toys that was
being released senior and he didn't
wanted to compete with them he wanted to
like he was really jazzed about toys and
he wanted to do well but Disney went
ahead and did it anyway and that's why
he was like no not doing the second
movie and then for the third movie they
threw like a boatload of cash I know
Ming's like okay I'm coming man Oh
interesting
someone says did we know any good racing
games for ps1 um the I mean there's a
friggin the racing 1 crash team now yes
crash no oh my goodness that looks awful
holy crap they should've at least in
like a 2d animated intro like the other
movie or the other games [ __ ] twisted
metal yes twisted metal I'm sorry see ya
cork on that car combat racing game
racing well yeah YouTube says are you
guys kidding me this game is a technical
and creative masterpiece out Chang
mario64 is ocarina assume he's referring
to hundred two Dalmatians I'm sorry we
have we had to dump it visually eight
yeah oh yeah and Gran Turismo it's Jeff
are like a Star Wars ghost he's phoning
his performance in Tokyo Highway battle
for ps1 says that later some middle
school of theater I'm acting right here
[Music]
is it he like the Prince for you he's
hamming it up he the Sultan now he's not
a street right anymore they really made
that clear huh well I mean like he's if
this takes place like after the first
eleven he technically is the Sultan but
he prefers to wear his street rat
clothes for I don't know why oh my god
this is gone weird she's awake you know
her eyes are open
taking her by the hand come on go oh
there is a sultan oh boy Oh Liam by his
face oh boy this was bad Joey I will I
will argue that this is the most
cinematic out of all the the game so far
right that we've checked out all right
let's do this all right I think this is
a 2d or 3d it's gonna be 3d right yeah
according to them to the box no memory
card well we really gotta get a memory
card if we wanna you know bring it back
what are you pressing extra circle or
triangle that I press R on
continuing that Oh continue about saving
yes I I just hit I assumed it my like do
you want to say more cutscenes yeah like
she saved the world it has like oh and
he still wears his like same outfit with
the patch on it yeah stuff where's that
I'm a little bit is do you think that's
the same voice for a lot sounds like
Homer does yeah this is gotta be some
kind of mistake also I don't think you
smell the coffee people just people in
Agra just eat hummus breakfast time do
you think we have a copy of um Simpsons
the movie game oh definitely cuz that
I'm pretty sure we do that game is not
awesome
but I like that game that game they went
they put a lot of effort into it and it
doesn't fully work I think the ending
gets kind of an you know the further it
goes but I remember that game having
like a lot of charm and they they they
put some serious effort into it yeah
what about Oh
hit and run we have that ok well I'll
say up front
Aladdin's movement is very responsive
notice yeah this is way better the jumps
a bit um Prince of Persia one I mean
like like the 2d Prince of Persia yeah
but there's no like that he does have
that window for the
right just the way he does that yeah all
right we got the voice talents oh yes
dan council another Scot leader Lord
this a little bit gilbert godfree's dona
jonathan freeman so it's basically the
entire cast of a legend for this return
too far at least not the original Jim
Cummings is in here too never I don't
you talk about hummus is a breakfast
food I've actually never had a hummus
for breakfast I haven't just new jeiza
snack yeah well I mean times were
different back or current I'm not even
sure what year
Aladdin actually takes place because
it's in weird country
[Music]
compound
[Music]
I can't tell what this meat is this
music trying to be a Latin issue like is
it specifically aping a specific Aladdin
track or is it just trying to be I think
it's just like general like they maybe
they just didn't want to use the exact
same like music from the movie oh happy
pop in grace it from the show yeah that
pop in is oh wait wait go to the edge
again you can keep it if you did that
little like whoa balancing thing
[Music]
boy thanks I'm sensing a bonus round
Strang get it then cut them off
[Music]
what's uh what we give this Oh as far as
the score goes for this game
[Music]
all right this one this one was reviewed
on April 5th 2001 cool
the lead is there are flashes of
Disney's Magic in several aspects of the
series revenge but it isn't enough to
overcome the game's technical Shane
Satterfield
I remember him the sort for GameTrailers
gave it a 6 point 3 at the time the
voice acting is excellent because you
know it does have most of the cast from
like later on that opening wasn't that
great okay there's like a block and
everything oh there's a block it's like
a whole is Dark Souls go this box
Disney's Dark Souls you do like a slide
yeah man this is a good amount of
mechanics and I like slide into an
attack you can't do a slide attack I'm
assuming the slide is an attack already
like owner if it trips them those juice
boxes yes and like a priests on or
health through helps
Yurika says it's weird that ps1 looks
worse than Super Nintendo now it's just
that three when you think about it
doesn't age well it's like you know
Super Nintendo was like the peak of 2d
right and this is like the original 3d
the same way we look at like Atari and
we're like that doesn't hold up yeah
that was like the original 2d right I
think some ps2 games hold it better and
I think cuz a lot of ps2 games cuz the
graphics store and good enough that they
did a lot of oh man like cartoonish yeah
looks and that makes them hold up a lot
better it's really like ps3 360 games
don't worry cuz they're trying to be a
more realistic graphics and like there's
like this view like a middle ground that
doesn't really look great but it's not
stylized enough either to make it look
like hold up previously well like that
are like wise graphics at a point but
those early games like no way I'm gonna
train to that slide oh they totally did
hit him why he killed him too just rats
you're a murderer Bob dude is talking
about the the evidence that I heard
about this too that Aladdin actually
takes place in a post-apocalyptic future
but just sowed away
where they eat hummus for breakfast yeah
like you can shoot right I guess
oh you shoot throw those apples on them
okay yeah nice get it I get the genie
cool
yeah floating platform okay and I hit
that
[Music]
it's coming for you it Travis the PSone
guards do have a certain charm to them
like there's a reason why it's it's kind
of a trend right now to D make no now
ocular games I don't know if you've seen
the the ps1 Assassin's Creed oh yeah
that's cool like it's it because people
like ok looking back on stuff like this
it's not like it's not even really like
an argument that this game looks kind of
bad but it just has something about it
like it just holds like those memories
that people have and that's why people
like appreciate that look yeah at least
for the good ones not not like low
Mermaid - Wow ok harem what the UM
remember in there in in the original
land in one jump when he slides down
through the the clotheslines right and
there from the first scene yeah and he
sees those ladies that like oh it's
Aladdin gonna bother that's a couple one
man rising crime they like him because
he's broke or they don't like it because
he's broke they're like oh this guy
can't always in here without any money
hey I gotta win I won this misadventure
since this city is made of bread
[Music]
Oh
again I can't though Monica wins
cheerleader in whoa go Amanda Audio
audio is breaking jellies
mmm that sounds awful I hope that's not
on our end
no that's the game
oh boy no it's 71 it doesn't punish you
at least
damn so well that first it is that you
have to do it over and over again
Oh dan dan I was like done pretty good
little to Agra buggins
was it Accra in the first one mm-hmm oh
it's one right there
grab that throw it in there can you
choose what the throw it in Martin whose
know this is actually yes it just
doesn't this is not emulation we are
actually playing on a real ps1 hmm
converted through a framemeister into
HDMI and so what you see right here on
the street
yep is the original game on disk
however unfortunate that might that
might be
oh there's actually a description for
what each level or what the engine will
wash it does oh okay
[Music]
it's a fire guy I'm gonna make him choke
and die he's already suffered enough
I did oh yeah I just hot coals in the in
the back alley of this place
[Music]
oh that yeah Devon hall the the Disney
skateboarding game you might know I know
it was it was called disney skate
adventure and basically it was like a
full-fledged tony hawk clone but with
disney characters like it was actually
there's actually really cool you could
play as like Buzz Lightyear can have
like their own characters you could play
as Simba from Lion King somehow he would
just be on all fours uh it's not a lot
of skateboarding no he was most people
really like oh you could do like the
same kind of tricks it had that be cool
control scheme as Tony Hawk's Pro Skater
which is like surprising okay I think it
was made by Activision as well I don't
remember
pick up my heaven at home does it use
the same logo font that you strollers
Tony Hawk games go Disney it was like
really quick
[Music]
this was kind of weird though oh yeah
had a kid Tarzan as well
[Music]
yeah Martin I don't know it was that
that was just that one level that was
like glitching out on the audio it's
kind of weird
yeah some up with the game you could be
turk from Tarzan be Woody have like a uh
a wagon skateboard anything oh I gotta
throw an apple out
[Music]
and you get back or just slide into the
library
[Music]
okay
oh the framerate swing slide geez
oh you threw an apple on man oh he's
blocking all your talks all my attacks
yeah you have to go all the way back up
no no
how am I supposed to kill him oh I don't
this slant attack
yeah I got what you can jump out of that
man you swing more like back and forth
it's a fire guy yep well as long
wielding sobbing oh good line it up line
it up a little bit to the right okay
there you go nice it's got a can you
change the camera there you go yeah that
way this guy's practicing he sees II was
like okay I got it
got it he gotta get ready for when he
shows up chief Fox give me more more
ropes here
get the key don't miss now oh yeah yeah
sick absolutely go all the way back
the controls are fairly responsive
not bad yeah the controls are not bad
the combat is pretty
she's good I think you have to go on
wait yeah you're not gonna make that
though if you go onto that platform
first I might I think I can yeah okay
Yago thank you for now well what does a
camel dangerous to go alone
three key we're actually yeah we're
moving along we're not having we haven't
gotten stuck anywhere yet thankfully
this game seems totally fine it was fine
what's kinda yeah I think it's fine I
don't necessarily want to keep it but I
think it's ok it's like it's one of
those weird games where it's like okay
there's nothing wrong with it there's
also nothing like intruder balance yeah
it's not it's like it's just incredibly
generic right yeah it's kind of whatever
to me okay we are running low on time
though yeah let's say let's take a look
at the Knicks level and if it's like if
it's just another Agrabah
back-alley thing then we'll we'll end it
there make our decision and then it's
off the street yes then again
[Music]
got you got in the Syrah thumbs down
oh you only got two
would you like to join the PlayStation
underground absolutely another Agrabah
level surprise I was a magazine Oh the
station underground we said you like
demo disks and stuff what is that what
does that guy out there have in store
for you but you do not need them in
order to get past the guard will talk to
the genie over there
did you know that you can taste God's
dispose of enemies and hit targets by
throwing apples at better means there's
something about like yeah I think he's
like there's a point where he just like
yawns he's dabbing right now typical
Agrabah dabs Frank
we could pay you you just give them one
of these coins great oh yeah pick any up
kill him Hey missing some now he's like
go he's actually asleep he was filmed
snore
[Music]
[Music]
he wakes up it's got to be like a sorry
I'm giving you one more chance and then
were oh wait oh no we can crouch
that does that uh here did you know that
you can days dogs dispose put your sword
away put your sword away using triangle
then press the circle button then you
need to speak to the apples
oh-oh-oh yeah that's pretty good that's
actually pretty good
are you gonna wait you got the way okay
okay not too far because then he's just
not gonna be there anymore from toga
sneak in there don't mind me just taking
a stroll
[Music]
I think I think it's enough apples kill
that guard well maybe they're for later
he's using vulnerable to apples just go
to the door next
got'em what's up here it better be
something good this better be worth it
okay now I think that guy you need to
[Music]
okay think we're running low on time
here we got a cake though I'm gonna
check your [ __ ] old man juice box
[Music]
whoa you can go there oh man this is
actually pretty high up the Agrabah like
skyscrapers dang that's fall to your
death ten stories up actually say is not
bad it's totally okay but still gonna
have to say no I don't want I don't
think it's worth keeping no worth
keeping
aliens work either yeah it's like it
feels incredibly generic and yeah I
think we better off without it
all right cool well let's get to
fullscreen here close out the episode
thanks everyone for watching the very
first just camera oh there we go no
that's no no hi hey everybody sorry
about that thanks for watching this
first episode of game dump I hope you
guys had a good don't put those a good
dump with us yeah we're gonna try and do
this as much as possible on Fridays me
and Joey I'm gonna be swapping in out
different consoles different games might
get some people on for this we have so
many bad games in there we can probably
do this for a while so hopefully you
guys enjoyed it and feel free to hit us
up with recommendations for like games
you'd want to see or consoles you want
to see covered you can you know leave a
comment when I so Twitter yeah I follow
us on Twitter a John Luke psyche and
uncle fuzz yeah these four are being
dumped yep sad to say marzan has been
saved so surprising it was the first one
that we played saving it and then don't
be like next four cuz it was the first
one so we didn't have any expectations
like if if we had gone if that gone last
it might have been domed might still
been dumped yeah see the adult Tarzan's
segments anyway again my name is joy
this is John
we're here every Friday 11:00 a.m. don't
forget to subscribe and follow our
channels on YouTube twitch GameSpot calm
we'll have live streams we do we have
live streams every weekday at 11 a.m. so
make sure to catch those next one will
be on Monday with mmm who's gonna be
Mike and Jake and they do players that
now plays an umbel girl and so stay
tuned for that and we'll see you guys
next week bye